bonsoir à tous je vous propose ce soir
cinq personnages un vieux clown un [ __ ]
maçon à nogent un ouvrier
autogestionnaire et anarchistes un
psychiatre qui dit avoir eu de mauvaises
fréquentations et enfin un écrivain
américain de l'un des regrets
apparemment ces cinq personnages n'ont
rien en commun sinon qu'ils se situent
tous plus ou moins en marge de la
société c'est du moins ce qui m'est
apparu mais aux auteurs de répondre
voici donc le 159e numéro d' apostrophes
en marge de la société avec un point
d'interrogation
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
je vous présente
catherine paysan qui publie chez denoël
son dixième roman le clone de la rue
montorgueil c'est elle qui représentera
le vieux clown dont je parlais il ya un
instant kavanagh rédacteur en chef de
hara kiri de charlie hebdo qui publie un
récit autobiographique les [ __ ] chez
belfond le mas le [ __ ] le maçon italien
c'était son papa marcel mermoz en face
qui est celle ouvriers autogestionnaire
et
libertaire anarchiste dont je parlais à
l'instant aussi vous publiez des
entretiens avec jean marie domenach sous
le titre qui mois fait mon bonheur
l'autogestion c'est pas de la tarte aux
éditions du seuil et puis à côté de vous
gaston ferrière qui est médecin qui est
psychiatre et qui publie ses mémoires
sous le titre les mauvaises
fréquentations aux éditions jean claude
simoën m et puis à côté de moi
l'écrivain américain charles bukowski
et je dois dire quand
j'ai dit aux gens qui me connaissent que
je vous avais invité il ya eu tout de
suite deux clans le premier clan ça a
été assez quelle merveilleuse idée c'est
un très grand écrivain et ils m'ont
citait des phrases très élogieuse que
des gens si différents que jean paul
sartre philippe sollers
qui doit encore
bien kavanagh qui est ici et puis robert
sabatier et puis alphonse boudard on dit
sur votre oeuvre de dix ans vous êtes un
très très grand écrivain américain et
puis alors l'autre clan ils m'ont dit
mais tu es complètement fou tu as tort
d'inviter ce personnage il est pas
montrable parce que c'est un phallocrate
c'est un obsédé sexuel c'est un
pornographe c'est un alcoolique cette
info bref que des mots pas très gentil
alors je me demande est ce que l'un de
ces deux clans a raison ou bien est-ce
que
où ces deux clans peut-être ont-ils
raison
convaincu de beaucoup de choses
les choses les plus spectaculaires dont
on m'accuse sont évidemment en ferait
les choses les plus ternes sont fausses
quel que soit mon vrai personnage
c'est bien la vérité aux français ce que
je suis et ce que l'on lit de moi
mais je continue quand même
à diriger que ma vie mais sans cause
mais j'accepte ce qui advient
sans
tout ce qui est fait sans tout ce qui
est rajouté bien que une de mes ami e
hamadi que
nous
en fait je me suis trompé je me suis
trompé dans mon texte à j'ai dit moi
j'ai dit à une amie à une fille si je
deviens célèbre et si je deviens trop
ceux de voir qu'est ce qui m'arrivera
alors il m'a dit eh bien ne t'inquiète
pas parce que tu as tu t'es toujours
quand même cru plus que tu n'aies
voilà le au fond les les deux clans dont
je parlais ce 10 e st un si c'était les
indes pense que vous avez apporté une
certaine vérité dans ce monde c'est à
dire que vous dites les choses que
parfois d'autres écrivains ne veulent
pas dire et puis d'autres disent que au
fond c'est par vous que le scandale
arrive c'est peut-être aussi les deux
clans ont raison je crois
j'ai pas entendu la première partie de
la traduction d'un de vos propos mais
enfin il répète qu on ne s'inquiète pas
vous êtes vous êtes tantôt celui par qui
la vérité survient tantôt celui par qui
le scandale arrive
écoutez moi je dis pas je dis la vérité
est sans doute genre d' un peu la vérité
pour que les vérités deviennent
intéressantes
la vérité pour les philosophes
rites et des philosophes la vérité des
grands esprits de tous les temps et bien
c'est une vérité qui a été dit par eux
mais c'était une vérité tellement
ennuyeuse d'accord c'était la vérité
vraie sans doute mais c'était tellement
ennuyeux
que finalement personne ne les a écoutés
moi j'essaye de faire que la vérité soit
une jeune fille
en très joli petit souhait en minijupe
de manière à ce que les gens le
regardent au moins et que les gens est
en vie quand même de l'avoir agla
connaître
j'essaye vraiment d'ornellas vérité et
de manière ce qu'on s'y intéresse car la
vérité tout seul devrait être belle et
pas simplement quelque chose que l'on
doit connaître que l'on doit connaître
il faudrait que ce soit quelque chose
qui arrive à vous prendre littéralement
tout comme une barre 80 [ __ ]
les écrits les critiques français vous
compare à henri milet enfin disent que
vous êtes un peu dans la succession à
remy nerfs ça vous fait plaisir ou se
dire non au rouge lions toutes ces
galeries non ça c'est pas sérieux non
passer à la question suivante je vous
prie alors passer à d'autres sera vite
et non mais est ce que vous considérez
peut-être comme un solitaire comme un
marginal dans la littérature américaine
agiter un clodo toute ma vie quand même
et puis là on me paye pour écrire alors
on peut changer vraiment très marginale
quand même
évidemment parce que quand même dormir
dans un
jardin public une nuit puis le lendemain
pratiquement être payé pour ce qu'on
raconte c'est quand même assez
remarquable ça c'est marginal d'arriver
à une telle évolution sans leur annonce
je suis passé à l'intérieur de la
machine et ça ça me préoccupe beaucoup
ça m'inquiète beaucoup qu'est ce qu'il
va arriver à mon âme maintenant que je
suis à l'intérieur si on me donne trop
d'argent qu'est ce que je vais devenir
grave enfin je veux bien prendre le
risque alors donnez moi tous le fric que
vous voulez et alors c'était après c'est
mon problème merci beaucoup je m'en
occuperai way kavanagh pourquoi vous
avez dit que vous avez écrit dans votre
journal que
ducos qui était pour vous un grand
écrivain pourquoi c'est parce que c'en
est un oui mais pourquoi pourquoi
pourquoi quelque chose et vous pourquoi
quelque chose être très beau c'est comme
ça j'ai lu le kof ski j'ai pleuré de
plaisir je les relis je ne crois jamais
encore eu lieu hier
si heureuse il saute au plafond
j'étais direction un peu violente mais
enfin c'est comme ça bukowski parle de
n'importe quoi il parle je crois qu'il
ya des difficultés à les amasser des
histoires comme ça c'est son bouquet
compliquer ses petites histoires à
raconter il vomit avec ça il fait il
fait du beau jeu
il fait du plaisir pour moi pour moi
lecteurs il parle de n'importe quoi
c'est beau il parle oui il parle de lui
il parle d'eux beaucoup de lui passer
dessus de lui je vais
effectivement je parle
je veux me jeu j'en parle et je parle
des moments très douloureux pour tout un
chacun il est tout
cela et c'est tout ce que je peux faire
d'ailleurs je suis au front comme
papillon est né comme année et papillon
et ce papillon doit faire son métier de
papillon puis c'est tout
mais je ne suis pas un papillon je suis
plutôt un bond on sourit
bestioles assez dangereuse mais je fais
cela dit je fais ce que je fais
et je ne peux pas accepter que l'on
reconnaisse une valeur quelconque à ce
que je fais ça c'est bt des critiques de
faire histoire moi ce que je fais moi je
veux retourner dans ma chambre être seul
je veux pouvoir me promener dans une rue
et voir une [ __ ] qui se promènent sur
le trottoir c'est ça que je veux voir je
ne veux pas être connu en tant que grand
écrivain et je n'ai pas écrit pour être
connu en tant que grand écrivain j'ai
écrit pourquoi j'ai écrit au fond
pourquoi est ce que j'ai mais en tout
cas une fois qu'on a écrit quelque chose
est
fait par des télévisions ensuite et pour
moi c'est franchement un peu terrible
je connais beaucoup d'écrivains vous
états unis qui adorerait être ici que
moi là devant les écrans devant la
caméra entre deux tas de parler d'avoir
la possibilité de dire n'importe quoi
c'est formidable mais moi ça ne me fait
pas plaisir désolé mais saurisserie
sorry
mais je prends entre temps dont je parle
trop dr ferrières au fond charles
dickens est un personnage qui est
intéressant pour le psychiatre
commerciaux nord et comme je que je suis
ce qui lie kavanagh et qui écoute ce qui
dit écoute un petit peu c'est des
conseils qui donne tout en rigolant
n'est ce pas et puis ce que vous avez
nommés tout à l'heure par en pivot je
les lui ai bien j'ai pas pas participé à
la grande joie qui envahit kavanagh je
les lui avec des réserves j'ai sorti un
homme qui était isolé il m'a fait pitié
un peu par seconde à ce jeu vous rend
lui un très grand angoissé qui se
cherche mais je ne trouve pas cette
cette plénitude 7,7 cette humanité cette
communion avec le reste du monde que je
trouve que d'autres écrivains qu'ils
font sursauter avec elle on l'a comparé
si je vais pas refaire la comparaison
oui parce que le ruisseau j'avais pas vu
le soubresaut tout à l'heure je parle
renouveler oui
alors par conséquent j'avais fait
quelques réserves suis très content de
savoir qu'il a des fonctions digestives
rectal en particulier qui sont très bien
je suis très content de savoir qui
voguait facilité sans même de nausée ce
que j'admire aussi profondément qui du
côté sexuel il bat des records qui les
membres et d'une manière exceptionnelle
ça me fait beaucoup plaisir mais enfin
il ya autre chose que vous pensez pas
que cela est dit avec poésie comme
certains critères que je citais au début
il ya une poésie je ne nierai pas enfin
elle me transporte pas aux enjeux
communs transporte canada bien bon
lauriers pour vous vous
il ya quatre livres alors il y avait les
mémoires d'un vieux dégueulasse qu'est
paru aux éditions les humanoïdes
associés
pourquoi avez vous choisi ce titre
mémoires d'un vieux dégueulasse dans une
traduction des repas ce qu'il faut si le
très bon de philippe garnier
je t'aime et je n'ai même pas eu
l'astuce moins de trouver le type c'est
un journaliste qui
a vu kim a dit le dirigeant est un jour
dans la ligue et qu il m'a dit écoute
chez un vieux dégueulasse et crient donc
une rubrique qui s'intitulerait note
d'un vieux dégueulasse c'est lui qui l'a
inventé c'est pas moi ma vie celui-là je
suis responsable pour ce qui est arrivé
après d'accord
moi je suis finalement l'homme le plus
propre que la terre ait jamais vu je
suis un puritain ah bon
exactement
tout ce qui est sexuel m'excite dès que
je vois la nage fille d'une femme ça
m'excite puis je prendrai plume du coup
c'est pas un secret d'ailleurs
bon si je m'appelle je m'appelle un
vieux dégueulasse peut-être mais je suis
pas un vieux dégueulasse je suis tout le
contraire
voilà ça y est mais ventron maintenant
chute aux bons vont chuter maintenant je
vais me retrouver sur les bancs d'un
jardin public
mais enfin c'est comme ça est ce que je
peux m'adresser à vous non mais je vais
je faire quantité fort pour vous les
nouveaux contes de la folie ordinaire
son panneau s'agitaient dans une
traduction de jean françois bizot et
puis d'un autre de 2,2 léon mercadet
alors c'est pas tout à fait le titre
américain le titre est des plus
provocateur encore un américain quel est
le vrai titre
compte de la folie ordinaire
le vrai titre américain
oui en anglais c'est d'érection
éjaculation
troisième expédition cessa exhibition
merci et puis les contes
de la folie ordinaire j'ai vécu des mois
j'ai oublié parce que dès que j'ai écrit
juge oublier ce que j'ai écrit et ce qui
m'intéresse c'est ce qui va suivre donc
ce qui est franchement m'ennuie mais ce
que ça ne me plaît plus mais ce que vous
venez pas là la preuve vivante de la
décadence américaine
non moi je suis certainement à leur
représentation vivant de mme à des
cadences et je vis aux états unis sans
doute ça ça fait partie d'un tout tout
est dans tout seul mais bon je suis
dégâts dans non non je ne suis pas
décadent je suis un malheureux à méru
chauffeur finalement je n'ai pas de
métier j'ai pas beaucoup d'instruction
j'essaye de me débrouiller j'essaie
d'avoir de quoi bouffer j'essaye de
trouver une femme le seuil bas j'essaye
toujours on te dirai essayé mais je
réussis pas tellement j'ai pas beaucoup
de chance comment vous en trop aux
balades dans l'ordre moi je vais bien lu
les femmes vous en trouver beaucoup aux
relations j'en ai trouvé moi que vous un
oui par exemple
alors quatrième livre qui est l'amour
est un chien d'enfer cétacés très beau
titre aux éditions du sagittaire avec
une dans une traduction de gérard guégan
et
l'indicé des prix on peut dire c'est des
poèmes des chroniques c'est difficile de
dire enfin l'indicé appelons les poèmes
comment se fait-il que vous soyez dans
l'annuaire en effet d alors vous dites
les gens de téléphone me pose cette
question êtes vous réellement charles
bukowski d'écrivain et il s'étonne que
vous soyez dans l'annuaire pourquoi
êtes-vous dans l'annuaire
lorsque
dès que j'ai publié ce poème je fais
supprimé mon nom de l'annuaire très
rapidement
la raison est évidente parce que ça
sonnait tout le temps je n'avais pas
dormi
les jambes téléphone et 8 ans en me
disant voilà j'ai se vouer sauvé la vie
c'est formidable mais ils disent mes
jeux il disait aussi je voudrais venir
vous voir je voudrais bien boire avec
vous et je peux pas voir avec le monde
entier quand même j'arrive à avoir pas
mal merci beaucoup mais je veux pas
quand même voir avec le monde entier
quand même et puis dans un autre de ses
poèmes vous donner des conseils comment
devenir un grand écrivain je veux pas le
tout le site et mais c'est assez bizarre
tout de même vos catherine paysan
j'espère visionner les prix de tout ça
il ya des choses que j'aime beaucoup
dans cet enchaînement
oui qu'est-ce que vous aimez un bas
parce que j'aime bien c'est écrit valor
j'aime le côté enbil si vous voulez de
bukowski c'est à dire que il en remet
évidemment du point de vue pour nous
auxerre a envoyé un bon rythme c'est
difficile avec une traduction vous savez
comme moi que la poésie quand on la
traduit c'est toujours quand même une
trahison même quand elle est très bien
très bien traduites en mai est ce que
j'aime chez lui il sera peut-être pas
content mais je le dirai quand même
s'est il a quelquefois une nostalgie de
la respectabilité alors pour ça épatant
[Musique]
comme j'ai remarqué à dos les facilités
dont certains ont la nostalgie d'être
des marginaux lui ça c'est sûr il
voudrait tellement avoir une petite sont
correctes
il boite un petit bourgeois mais oui de
temps en temps du moins il a besoin de
se faire ce cinéma-là de nancy
non mais je dis ça parce que ça m'a
beaucoup intéressé mais je regrette si
vous voulez de ne pas pouvoir le lire la
langue c'est toujours très vite est ce
que vous pensez qu'il aimerait ne pas
boire qui s'est assagi à cette question
je ne sais pas s'ils préfèrent boire
aussi des mre ne pas être soumis au fait
de boire 1 ça c'est une question de
libre arbitre et partitions personnes
âgées partie de son personnage ça je ne
peux pas me mettre dedans ça pour ça
enfin ça ça m'a intéressé c'est
comment de voeux
comment devenir un grand écrivain les
conseils que vous donnez charles
bukowski et vous ne direz pas après ça
que vous n'êtes pas un provocateur
comment devenir un grand et qu'il va
vous devez baiser de mac il va vous
devez baiser de max